Лучше совершить 10 маленьких ошибок, чем
одну большую. Я заработала свой первый
миллион 8 лет назад. Вы можете начать с
любого бизнеса, с любых сумму. Нельзя
болеть, нельзя подводить. И это не моя
проблема, как ты вылечишься. Ничего
себе. И там человек скач полный, как
говорится. У наставника тоже есть
наставник. Бизнес - это искусство или
наука? Наука. Друзья, привет. С вами
Маргулан Сизимбай, и это Беседы. Я решил
запустить новый формат на своём YouTube
канале.
Этот формат называется беседы. И этот
формат очень простой и очень древний,
как древнегреческая философия. Я на
самом деле этот формат взял у древних,
э, древнегреческих философов, которые
проводили беседы со своими учениками или
со всеми людьми, которые к ним
приходили, со своими вопросами. И этот
формат на котором мы будем обсуждать
любые темы. И вы, кстати, зрители тоже
можете принять в этом участие.
Обязательно оставьте заявку, вашу тему.
ваши вопросы. Если вы, э, можете хорошо
задавать вопросы и вести себя как
интервьюер, то мы обязательно вас
пригласим на беседу со мной. А сегодня у
нас в гостях Анжелика Кайратова, очень
известный человек в Кыргызстане,
общественный деятель, а, творческая
личность, а человек, который посвятил
творчеству очень много лет своей жизни.
Очень хорошая моя знакомая. Мы вместе
ездили даже в путешествие, но не вместе.
вдвоём, а, имеется в виду большой группу
людей. Очень открытый, хороший, добрый
человек. И у Анжелейки возникли вопросы,
которые она собрала от предпринимателей
Кыргызстана. И вот сегодня мы с как раз
побеседуем. И ещё раз хочу подчеркнуть,
что это не формат интервью, это беседы,
где мы будем обсуждать и не обязательно
мы будем давать готовые ответы, потому
что когда это интервью, там понятно,
есть вопрос, есть ответ. В формате бесед
не обязательно вы получите готовые
рецепты, готовые ответы, но вы получите
сам процесс обсуждения. И вполне
возможно, именно с процесса обсуждения
вы возьмёте больше. Итак, Анжелика.
Здравствуйте ещё раз. Всем привет. А для
меня сегодня такой исторический день, и
был ровно год тому назад тоже такой же
день, потому что именно 28 марта, а
сегодня 29 марта, я познакомилась с
вами. Серьёзно? Да. Сегодня год. О,
ничего себе. Впервые я вас увидела аж в
Сан Пауло. Я прилетела, искала Маргулана
Колеевича, его не видно. И вечером у нас
собрали на ужин. А, где мы, а,
представляли себя. Ага. И я, а-а, тогда
м уже, можно сказать, открыла для себя
совсем новую другую дверь. А я туда м
без никаких целей полетела, хотела
исполнить свою свою детскую мечту. Угу.
А я всю жизнь мечтала увидеть Бразилию,
но никогда не знала, с кем туда полечу и
как это случится. Но кланы Всевышнего,
как всегда, оказались намного лучше. Я
увидела Риода Жанейру на одном вертолёте
с вами. Да. И чего я желаю всем, кто
хочет на мастермайн, на такую поездку.
Классная поездка, кстати, была. И
Анжелика была украшением той поездки, на
самом деле. Ээ, решайтесь и
присоединяйтесь, потому что в прямом
смысле моя жизнь изменилась полностью
после этой поездки. Спасибо большое. Я
очень рад такое слышать. Да, спасибо
большое. Оказалась в клубе Кайзен, где я
нашла новых друзей.
единомышленников.
И каждый раз, когда я на сессиях, я
участвую у
вас, не успеваю, как задать вам вопрос,
уже получаю ответы. Ну вот сегодня у
тебя как раз такая возможность. Ты
собрала кучку вопросов. Давай. Сегодня у
нас тема ещё небольшое уточнение. Каждая
беседа у нас проходит по одной теме. Это
делается для того, чтобы не распылять
ваше внимание, дорогие зрители, и чтобы
в плейлисте потом вам легче было
находить нужное видео. То есть вы просто
смотрите по темам и легко
ориентироваться и находить то, что вас
непосредственно интересует. У нас
сегодня тема бизнес. Вот мне всегда
интересно. Я как стартаппер и у меня 12
действующих бизнесов. Я м как у
стартапера 12 бизнесов. Ну, ты уже не
стартапер, ну, какой-то ты уже серийный
стартапер. Ну, я люблю делать старты. Э,
я люблю рисковать, и я делюсь своим
бизнесом с лучшими сотрудниками.
А, и как раз-таки будут вопросы на эти
темы. А больше ли вкладывают вообще вот
деньги в начинающий бизнес или при
масштабировании мы больше тратим
всё-таки? Где предприниматели больше
вкладывают именно деньги? А ты знаешь,
на самом деле многие думают, что надо
больше вкладывать в самом начале, но я
просто знаю многих предпринимателей,
которые в начале вообще особо ничего не
вкладывают. А, но я точно знаю, что а
все 100% предпринимателей не обходят вот
чего. Все 100% предпринимателей больше
денег теряют на своих ошибках. То есть,
если брать бизнес весь как процесс, а
есть начало, ну, ну, конец не буду
говорить, есть начало, есть зрелость
бизнеса, да, и вот где человек вот
масштабирование, возьмём, зрелость
бизнеса, есть начало, есть
масштабирование. Так вот, больше всего
предприниматели теряют денег в середине.
Угу. Пока они дорастут до этого уровня
на своих ошибках, потому что на ошибках
потери идут колоссальные. И самое, а,
прискорбное в том, что когда бизнесмены
занимаются бизнесом, он уже начал
бизнес, он уже вложил туда деньги, он
уже вложил свою энергию время. И когда
он совершает ошибки и уходит в минус и
либо теряет деньги, он это бросить уже
не может. Он в безвыходной ситуации он
должен продолжать. И поэтому вот это
самое фатальное и самое страшное.
Поэтому, а, я считаю, больше надо
уделять
внимание не тому, сколько там в начале
там. Это не критично. Вы можете начать с
любой суммы. И более того, я вам скажу,
можете начать любой бизнес, даже в какой
нише не имеет значения. Смотрите, а,
приведу вам аналогию. Есть вообще в мире
две системы, м, условно говоря,
достижения целей. Первая система, я
называю это артиллерийская, чтобы легче
понять. Вот представьте ствол пушки, да?
Угу. Стреляешь и там через 10-15 км
снаряд попадает куда-то. Так вот, у
артиллерийской системы вот здесь снаряд
вылетает. Снаряд только болванка
срычатыми вещами, она летит, да. Так
вот, есть такой математический закон,
который называется м чувствительность к
начальным условиям. Если вы пушку здесь
на 2° хотя бы отклоните, то там в конце
вы не то, что в цель не попадёте, там
снаряд на 200-300 м далеко от цели
уйдёт.
Почему? Потому что снаряд летит как
болванка. Угу. И многие люди думают, что
вот достижение цели именно такое. Надо
цель поставить и к ней идти точно
прицелиться. Поэтому очень тщательно
спрашивают: "А каким бизнесом заняться?
В какую нишу пойти там и не начинает
бизнес". А я говорю и призываю:
"Действуйте как ракета". Что делает
ракета? Она
вылетает, потом у неё в заднице
загорается своя свой двигатель. Здесь
есть головка наведения. И вот цель может
быть там. Она вылетает сюда, но она по
ходу начинает разворачиваться и находить
цель. И более того, ракета же попадает в
движущуюся цель, то есть в летящий
самолёт. Самолёт от него улетает,
убегает, а она за ним гоняется. Так и
бизнес. Вы можете начать с любого
бизнеса, с любого бизнеса, с любой ниши,
с любых сумм. Главное начать. Как только
вы начали, начинает работать в вашу
пользу, так, я так называю, кривае
обучение. То есть, чем больше вы чем-то
занимаетесь, тем больше вы обучаетесь,
тем больше вы ориентируетесь, люди к вам
приходят, возможности начинают приходить
и так далее, и так далее. И таким
образом, на самом деле, вот это очень
важно, а, понимать, что в конечном итоге
вы всё равно совершите много ошибок.
Угу.
Но лучше вот это делать не не на той
стадии до начала. Вот мы, кстати, забыли
упомянуть, вот ты задала вопрос в начале
бизнеса, масштабирование середин, да?
Так многие люди ещё теряют не деньги, но
время и энергию для того, чтобы начать
бизнес. Они даже не начинают бизнес. Так
вот, начинайте любой бизнес, по ходу
разберётесь. А если говорить с точки
зрения, где теряются основные деньги,
основные деньги теряются на неправильных
решениях, на ошибках.
А для этого вот я бы рекомендовал, что
делать? Чтобы минимизировать ошибки,
надо стартовать с малого, с небольших
сумм. А лучше совершить 10 маленьких
ошибок, чем одну большую. 10 маленьких
ошибок исправить и чем совершить одну
большую. Вот разве в творческой
деятельности это не так? Это по-другому.
Ну и вот смотри, ты какой-то проект
начинаешь. Ага. Вот как ты считаешь,
тебе надо сразу всё идеально сделать или
вот когда вот ты бренд, у тебя крутой
очень бренд, куча подписчиков и вот ты
начинал как сразу идеально или как-то ты
вот скажи, ну как певица, если из 100
песен, ну максимум пять, наверное, они
будут хитами, но до хитов ты должна
пробовать петь разные мелодии разными
композиторами, что-то нет, что-то
нравится, что-то нет. Ты просто ждёшь,
когда придёт твой час, но при этом ты
записываешь альбомы за альбомами. Ну,
работаешь. Ну, работаем всегда, да. А
что касается в бизнесе, у меня,
мм, интуитивно всё идёт. Я начинаю, мне
это нравится. Самое главное, что я сама
нуждаюсь именно в этом продукте. Я хочу
его продавать. Я сама хочу себя купить.
И я начинаю потом писать проект, как я
могу правильно его продать. Ну, ты как
творческий человек подходишь. Ты знаешь,
на самом деле, вот меня спрашивают:
"Бизнес - это искусство или наука?" Вот
в моём понимании бизнес - это наука, это
чёткий технологический процесс. В твоём
понимании бизнес - это искусство. И я не
скажу, что я прав или там ты права. А
очень важно ещё привязывать это к той
личности, которая делает бизнес. Потому
что некоторые люди, я знаю творческих
людей, которые плохо считают, плохо
считают, бухгалтерии почти не
разбираются, но при этом делают хороший
бизнес. То есть поэтому вот и ещё такой
ответ, что когда ты этот вопрос хоть и
не задала, просто он у нас спонтанно
появился, да? Каков правильный подход к
бизнесу как к искусству или к бизнесу
как науке, технологии, системе? Ребята,
каждый выбирайте под себя в зависимости
от своего понимания, темперамента, что
вас драйвит и так далее. Вот в твоём
случае, видишь, ты интуитивно
двигаешься. Ну нормально же получается.
Ну у меня получилось, наверное,
благодаря мм практике, которую я уже
внутри этой системы научилась, внутри
бизнеса, скажу, да? То есть я бы сама
самостоятельно не смогла бы открыть,
допустим, компанию, чем я сейчас в
основном сейчас занимаюсь. Я продаю
квартиры в недвижку в Дубае, в Турции.
Угу. И получилось так, что они
обратились как блогеру, инфлюенсеру. Я
поехала, посмотрела и начала уже
интересоваться комиссиями. М. И я сразу
же стала риэлтором, брокером и так
далее. Открыла потом свою компанию и
начал. Вот ты, ну, ну, ты смотри, ты же
не сидела, не спрашивала, какую нишу мне
пойти, каким бизнесом заняться. тебе
предложил ли ты раз и начала заниматься?
Ну, я больше, наверное,
предложила, потому что я посчитала, что
а мои подписчики, скажем так, окружения
платежеспособны, и я могу правильно
донести
именно нишу инвестирование в
недвижимость. И это у меня круто
получилось. Я заработала свой первый
миллион 8 лет назад. Круто, круто. Ну,
мм, наверное, у всех, у многих скажу,
да, предпринимателей - это боль именно в
сотрудниках, как их правильно подобрать,
где их нужно, да, вообще искать. Ну,
есть методы управления у меня, они такие
демократичные. Ну, хочешь, работай,
покажи, на что ты способен. А потом я
начинаю уже добавлять им, ну, комиссии,
там, скажем. Угу. Или интересую
подарочками, как вы рекомендуете. Дарите
путешествия не только человеку. Нужные
вещи. Нужные подарки нужно, да, дарить.
А здесь вот именно какие методы
управления командами вы считаете
устаревшим устаревшими, да? Ну я не
знаю. Команда управ командой нужно
управлять, но есть именно
где аа такой жёсткий контроль есть. Это
как в системе Apple, да, я скажу, они
прямо такие требования потом начинают с
вот хай, да, с самой высокой точки.
А Google начинает наоборот снизу, они
там ничего не требуют, говорят: "Покажи
себя, покажи себя", потом начинаешь
расти. Угу. А есть ли определённа такая
система, которая устарела, которую не
стоит сейчас? Ну, знаешь, хороший
вопрос. Мне нравится в этом плане подход
такой. М, ну, раньше я увлекался разными
системами управления, думаю, какое
хорошее, какое преимущество лучше, хуже.
И в этом деле самое лучшее - это
руководство китайским принципам, которые
гласит: "Неважно, какого цвета кошка,
лишь бы она мышей ловила". Поэтому с
точки зрения управления нужно понимать,
вот есть диктаторский стиль, когда
приказом ты говоришь, ты говоришь, что
делать, когда и так далее. Есть
демократический стиль, когда ты
работаешь методом убеждения. Угу. А если
брать в целом плюсы и минусы,
диктаторский стиль, он тоже хорош, но он
хорош в начале бизнеса, он хорош во
время кризиса. Угу. Для того, чтобы
компанию вытащить из кризиса, там не
надо цацкаться, там нужно просто делать,
поменьше болтать, больше делать. Поэтому
диктаторский стиль, есть определённой
отрасли, где диктаторский стиль важен. А
плюс диктаторский стиль зависит от
уровня. Например, чем ниже уровень
управления, тем больше диктаторский
стиль. Чем выше уровень управления, тем
больше демократический стиль управления.
Потому что топ-менеджеры всё-таки это
люди более осознанные. И поэтому вот
этот стиль определяется ещё
осознанностью твоих
сотрудников. А, но в то же время вы
должны понимать основные принципы
управления вообще. А если брать бизнес,
он состоит на самом деле из двух больших
блоков. Первое, принятие решений, а
второе, осуществление этих решений или
претворение в жизнь этих решений. Так
вот, на стадии принятия решения лучше
всего демократический стиль, потому
что если один человек принимает решение,
то у него большая вероятность ошибиться.
Поэтому вот на стадии принятия решения
лучше советоваться с людьми, спрашивать
их мнение, советоваться со своим
топ-менеджментом и так далее. Но после
того, как вы приняли решение, там нужна
диктатура, потому что вот представь, мы
с тобой совещались, договорились о
чём-то, а потом начинаем думать: "Ой, а
я думал вот так, мы же договорились,
ожелика, ну какой всё. После того, как
договорились, после того, как приняли
решение, должна быть диктатура". И вот
здесь Исха Адизис, вот израильский
бизнес-тренер, хорошо сказал, он
придумал такой термин, который
называется демократура.
диктатура с демократией объединил,
назвал демократура. Это когда решения
принимаются демократическим
большинством, а исполнение происходит
через диктатуру. Поэтому нельзя сказать,
что какая-то система управления устарела
или не устарела. Все инструменты
действуют, потому что психология людей
за там тысячелетия не менялась. Вот я
читаю древних греков то же самое или
древних философов. Не психология людей
не меняется. И для того, чтобы людьми
управлять, нужно в то же время
управление - это такой наука, э,
контекста. Всё зависит от контекста, в
каком ты управляешь. В каком-то надо
поголовки погладить, в каком-то надо
пинка отдать
хорошего, в каком-то накричать. Это же
зависит, смотри, зависит от контекста,
то есть ситуации, и зависит от личности,
с кем ты разговариваешь. Потому что
бывает так, что ты в критической
ситуации, надо применить диктатуру. Но
если с тобой рядом человек осознанный и
всё понимает, не надо диктатуру. То
есть, видите, поэтому очень важно такую
вещь понимать, в какой ситуации какой
стиль управления работает. И второе,
понимать, с каким человеком какой стиль
управления работает. А устаревшие или
там не устаревшие, это, ну, не совсем
точная
классификация. Вот у вас у творческих
людей Угу. с творческими людьми надо
по-особому, например, управлять с ними.
Там их вовлекать по-другому, надо
разговаривать с ними
по-другому. Но у вас в вашей среде, вот
интересно, я не сам не из творческой
среды. У вас больше как работает, когда
режиссёр жёсткий или он совещается
или или продюсер?
Ну мо у меня не было
продюсера, кто диктовал. се я сама себя
продюсерменеджер, а, ну понятно. И
мобилограф и так далее мамщик. В общем,
через всё это пришлось мне пройти,
потому что, ну, надо было, но мне, я
подозреваю, всё-таки вот представь, что
ты продюсер, да, и у тебя есть там
молодые певицы и так далее. Э, наверное,
всё-таки жёсткий метод не работает. Нет,
в творческой среде там люди
чувствительные. Всё-таки там наедешь в
истерику сорвутся. Нет. Мм, нет,
по-моему, у нас или у меня наоборот
нельзя болеть, нельзя подводить. Взяли
заказ, концерт послезавтра, у тебя
сегодня температура, нужно быстренько с
сочность сейчас вылечиться. И это не моя
проблема, как ты вылечишься. Ничего
себе. И там человеку скач полный, да?
Ну, иммунитет вырабатывается всё же. Это
тоже бывали моменты под 40 температурой
с ребёночком на руках мне приходилось на
площади под ми109 даже петь. Ну это
любовь, наверное, к своей работе больше.
Я же я воспринимаю люди творческие,
ранимые там то. Нет, мы больше,
наверное, идём именно на риски. Да.
Классно.
Ну, я всё вот это вот у вас спрашиваю
веду к тому, что а как можно вот ну вот
поделиться своим бизнесом с хорошим
сотрудником, да? Вот как вы понимаете,
что человек - это не просто хороший
сотрудник, а твой будущий
бизнес-партнёр? Потому что, в частности,
бывает такое, что мы, я начинаю сама
одна, и в ходе нашего сотрудничества я
начинаю предлагать определённую долюгу
и, ну, своему хорошему, лучшему
сотруднику. И это у меня прямо очень
хорошо получается по доходах. Мы растём
очень хорошо вместе. Ну вот, классно,
молодец. Ну, у тебя, значит, интуитивное
понимание есть. Просто ты не осознала до
конца. Но вопрос, конечно, это очень
интересный, но здесь
подводных камней тоже очень много.
Вообще давай мы рассмотрим эволюцию, как
вообще происходит рост, э, сотрудников в
компании и вообще эволюция компании.
Сначала ты надыбала какую-то тему, ты
начинаешь там что-то на базаре
продавать, сама бегаешь, тебе никто не
нужен. Зачем с кем-то делиться прибылью?
Ты сама бегаешь, всё. Но ты видишь,
спрос большой, можно масштабироваться, а
тебя не хватает. ты уже целыми днями
бегаешь, тебя не хватает, и ты что
начинаешь делать? Ты начинаешь брать на
работу родственников и друзей, потому
что те нужны люди, которые меньше просят
денег и чётко выполняют то, что ты
говоришь
безоговорочно. И это вторая стадия
бизнеса, когда в бизнесе появляются
родственники и друзья. И здесь работают
по принципу все занимаются всем. Нету
чёткого разделения, иерархии, там,
функционала и так далее. Через какое-то
время эта структура изживает, уже надо
расти, бизнес становится больше, надо
брать профессионалов. Бухгалтерию
начинается с бухгалтерии. Обычно
бухгалтерию берут, там юристов берут
профессиональных и так далее. Так вот,
профессиональные люди, их особенность в
том, что они не могут заниматься всем,
они занимаются только своим
функционалом. И вот когда бухгалтер
сидит и твой сотрудник прибегает,
который там родственник или друг и так
далее, говорит: "Дай срочно денег".
Анжелика сказал туда съездить. Он
говорит: "Нене, не, а бюджет как? Я
просто так не могу дать, а должно быть
решение". И он такой потом приходит к
тебе и говорит: "Анжелика, что ты мне
перестала доверять, что ли? Раньше я
спокойно брал деньги. Что за бухгалтер,
что там типок сидит там, ну что, деньги
мне не даёт и так далее". Появляется
первый конфликт между родственниками,
друзьями и профессиональными
сотрудниками. Всё. Собственник, если
хочет расти, он от родственников, друзей
избавляется, которые не хотят соблюдать
правила и работать. ээ, как положено, и
набирает профессиональную команду,
вернее, профессиональный коллектив. У
него профессиональный юрист, бухгалтер,
там кладовщик и так далее. Но эта стадия
третья, а на которой он создал
коллектив. Ещё нету команды, ещё
коллектив. Угу. И вот он продолжает
работать, и вдруг он начинает замечать,
что среди этих сотрудников есть
определённая категория, которые готовы
оставаться
дольше и которые готовы заниматься
больше, чем его функциональные
обязанности. То есть они начинают
грузиться больше. А мы же психологии как
кто грузится, того и грузим. Мы начинаем
грузить, и в какой-то момент такие люди
становятся
незаменимыми. И вот этот первый признак.
То есть тот человек, потенциальный
кандидат на партнёра, он должен
показывать большую вовлечённость. А что
такое вовлечённость? Это желание брать
на себя больше ответственности и
выполнять больше, чем предусмотрено его
функциональными обязанностями. То есть
человек больше грузится и выполняет не
только то, что вот ему положено, но и
даже больше этого.
И это уже, условно говоря, зачатки или
задатки партнёра, потому что партнёр
должен начать вкладывать частичку себя,
потому что когда он 8 часов отработал,
получил зарплату, вы квиты, а этот
человек отрабатывает не восемь, он уже
работает 10-12 часов, он уже своё личное
время, энергию тратит, он уже вкладывает
в твой бизнес душу. Всё. Это уже задатки
партнёра. Человек, который готов ради
твоего бизнеса вместе с тобой уже
рисковать и на кон ставить то, что у
него есть. Но у него ресурсы какие:
время и энергия. И вот, э, прежде всего
надо смотреть на вот это. Это первые
задатки. Второе, а прежде чем его делать
партнёром, нужно чётко посмотреть,
совпадают ли у вас ценности. Потому что
если ценности не совпадают, то в
дальнейшем будет конфликт. Что значит
ценности? Например, он считает,
например, что ценностью, э, это
благосостояние деньги, например. А вот
как есть же у кого же это язык любви? У
Эрихафрома, я не помню, у кого-то там
кто-то понимает язык любви в виде
подарков, кто-то в виде комплиментов,
кто-то в виде заботы и так далее. Так и
здесь нужно понять, что его драйвит, что
его увлекает. Его что драйвит? деньги
или рост, или амбиции, или смысл, или
ценности, которые ты транслируешь.
Желательно, чтобы у этого человека
ценности твои совпадали. И вот если
ценности совпадают, если ты видишь
высокий уровень вовлечённости, и третий,
надо смотреть его потенциал, насколько
далеко он может
вырасти, а это третий момент. И
четвёртый завершающий, на что надо
смотреть? Надо смотреть на его динамику.
растёт он или нет. Потому что бывают
люди в моменте хороши, но ты
развиваешься дальше и компания
развивается, и он многие партнёры так и
застревают и потом становятся обузой для
собственника бизнеса, потому что он не
растёт. Компания выросла, собственник
вырос, а этот на том же уровне, он
только мешает. И ещё хочешь у него
выкупить, так он ещё и цену заряжает.
Поэтому вот четвёртое. Обязательно
смотрите, чтобы партнёр, скорость
развития партнёра соответствовала
скорости вашего развития. Ну да, вы
прямо полностью рассказали, через что я
прошла, проходила и прохожу сейчас. А у
тебя сейчас сколько партнёров? У меня
сейчас а около 70.
70? Да. 70 сотрудников? Нет. Сотрудников
или партнёров? А партнёров. Я про
сотрудников всё думаю. Партнёров пять.
международной компании, а с которыми я
уже вот более 5-6 лет вместе встречаю в
Кыргызстане. У себя дома всегда проводим
масштабные форумы. И а был такой случай,
а у
нас я работала 3 года назад от сетевой
компанией. Угу.
И это такая очень тяжёлая работа с
людьми. А мне понравилась продукция
жизненно. Она мне очень сильно помогла в
своё время и захотела больше, чтобы люди
о ней узнали. И устроилась ко мне, а,
помогать домой девочка. Угу. Мм, и когда
я увидела её резюме с высшим
образованием, а просто там надо было ей
идти в какой-нибудь крутой офис,
устраиваться где-то на управление, она
тут пришла просто убираться ко мне
домой. Я ничего не стала спрашивать. И
через год
м я ей предлагаю, не хочет ли поработать
ещё доп дополнительно. И мы начали
как-то с ней онлайн уже работать вместе.
Я смотрю, у неё больше, лучше всё
начинает получаться. И таким образом
она, а, ну, после того, как я уже нашла
крутого классного менеджера у себя же
дома, Угу. я, а, выкупила франшизу этой
компании, стала представителем. Угу. и
предложила ей место директора. Угу.
Где-то 15-20 дней был шок у всех, то,
что были лидеры, бриллиантовые
директора, которые полностью систему эту
понимали, но при этом не понимали,
почему твоя девочка на побегушках, твой
ассистент, ну, она потом уже на до
ассистента выросла, которая нам кофе
приносила. Сейчас она там сидит,
говорит, и просит, чтобы мы с ней
стучались и заходили там, здоровались. И
в первую же очередь моя мама
отвернулась, говорит, и всё. Я, говорит,
я не могу ей подчиняться. Как так? Да.
И я уже начала замечать, что многие не
стали её признавать, её должность, и она
об этом тоже не может открыто мне
рассказать. И была такая фишка у меня
именно на тот момент. Я позвала
человека, который проводила м крутые
трансформационные игры. Ага. Это очень
круто помогло. Мне нельзя было
участвовать. Поиграли сотрудники вместе
с лидерами. И буквально через полчаса я
вижу, как она стоит на моём письменном
столе. И ей все апплодируют стоя.
Серьёзно? Да. Игра дошла до того, что
она стояла на столе и все её признавали
шефом. Так она на следующий день
поменяла своими. Слушай, это всёто она
игрева каса выходит, вышла.
пока, говорит, она не вырастет, пока вы
не не станете, говорит, её слушаться и
стучаться к ней, на вы обращаться,
говорит, пойдёт, говорит, туда. Да,
кстати, вот это очень важно тоже такой
момент. Игра классная вещь. Вообще любое
обучение через игру важно. Угу. А чтобы
этой девочке получить авторитет
руководителя, ей нужно было либо много
лет поработать и доказать свой
авторитет, либо ускоренно в игре
показать, что она авторитетный
компетентный человек, что и произошло.
Поэтому вот используйте потенциал игры.
У меня просто один из учеников, он
использует игру при наме людей. Он берёт
кандидатов и проводит с ними игру. А
когда проводят игру, кандидаты
расслабляются и ведут себя естественно.
И сразу видно, кто из них жадный, кто из
них готов по головам идти, а кто
наоборот скромный. Сразу видно в игре.
Нумы потихонечку потом уже убираем
некоторых лишних людей, которые, ну,
скажем, тяжёлые люди, да. Так, пока
подумают, мы уже тут, ну, видишь, ты ещё
женщина, у тебя преимущество в том, что
у женщин более сильно развита интуиция,
вы людей просчитываете лучше.
И это такая крутая была практика.
Представляете, она стала посещать салоны
красоты через день, то есть она начала
просыпаться, ну, раньше всех на
каблучках. А, ну она не совсем
миниатюрная, наверное. Все в команде
привет передаю. Вы знаете нашу самбатку,
да? И которая стала действительно
управлять достойно и купила квартиру
своей мечты, вышла замуж и открыла два
своих собственных компаний. И,
оказывается, просто нужно было поверить
в неё. И оказы очень важно а в работе
уметь подчиняться вышестоящим
руководителям. Да, ну это это да, как
без этого, да. Но вот вроде бы всё
классно идёт гладко, да, вот в бизнесе,
но ты в один момент чувствуешь, что ты
идёшь не туда. Ну если вроде всё идёт
даже по плану, да? Вот в какой момент
предпринимателю стоит отказаться от
стратегии? вообще не от стратегии, как я
сейчас
сформулирую. Как понять, что ты идёшь
неправильно, но ты всё равно заставляешь
себя пахать там, где уже стоп не стоит.
Ты же понимаешь, что уже дальше некуда
завершать нужно, потому что мы же
энергию ни туда не начинаем тратить.
Ну вот смотри, давай мм я начну с общего
философского понимания, да?
С точки зрения философского, для того,
чтобы понять, что ты идёшь не
туда, первая показатель, первый
показатель - это
когда то, что ты делаешь, не
соответствует тому, что ты считаешь
правильным. Угу. То есть то, что ты
делаешь, не соответствует тому, что ты
считаешь правильным. Либо то, что ты
делаешь, не доставляет тебе
удовольствие.
Либо то, что ты делаешь, не приносит
результата. Вот это три вещи. В идеале,
когда ты правильно делаешь, а то, что ты
делаешь, это соответствует тому, что ты
считаешь правильным, и ещё доставляет
тебе удовольствие, и ещё получается то,
что ты хотела. Угу. Вот три, три вещи.
То есть бывает так, что, а, какое-то
дело удовольствие приносит. И ты
считаешь правильным, но не даёт
результатов.
Тоже проблема. А бывает, что даёт
результатов, приносит удовольствие, но
ты не считаешь это правильным. Или
бывает, что считаешь правильным, даёт
результаты, но не приносит удовольствие.
Именно три вещи должны
быть. Тогда это то, что ты делаешь
правильно.
Теперь а ещё один фильтр надо
посмотреть, соответствует ли то, что ты
делаешь твоей миссии. Для этого нужно
сначала определить для тех, кто
определил свою миссию, соответствует
твоей миссии или нет. Первое. Второе,
соответствует ли это а твоим
стратегическим целям, долгосрочным
целям? Это два.
Третье. А работает ли время на
тебя? Четвёртое, работает ли место на
тебя? Угу. И пятое, работают ли
обстоятельства в твою пользу. Потому что
если время, место и обстоятельства
работают не на тебя, то это всё равно,
что
там против ветра ходить. Ну, у мужиков
есть такое, по-малому против ветра
ходить. А, а если это не соответствует
твоей миссии и твоим целям, то зачем
тебе туда вообще ходить? Поэтому вот
основные фильтры для того, чтобы понять,
а когда
надо, ну, остановиться или когда стоит
продолжать. И вообще ты своим делом
занимаешься или нет? Самое главное,
чтобы это не было лишь бы движением. Да.
Да. Не движение ради движения. Где
человек, который торгует цветами,
покупает в Узбекистане за 100 сом одну
розу и продаёт в Москве по 100 сомов. И
тоннами возит, оказывается. И там у него
друг спрашивает, говорит: "Ты каким-то
бизнесом займёшь?" Я тоннами, говорит,
розы доставляю. О'кей, говорит, ты почём
покупаешь, говорит, по 100, говорит,
почём продаёшь, говорит, по 100,
говорит, ты вообще же бизнесом не
занимаешься, говорит, лишь бы движение,
говорит, да, да, зато я тоннами же
редбороты делаю. Да. Вот поэтому каждый
раз, когда ты сама то, что ты делаешь, э
ты делаешь то, что тебе нравится. Так,
ну, иногда
бывает так, что, ну, кто тебя заставляет
делать? бет работа пашу. У меня нету
директора шефа, но я больше всех
сотрудников, наверное, Пашу. Я бы так
привыкла. Или или я не знаю, это уже
образ жизни. Это твоя компания. Это моя
компания. Ну вы извините меня, ну почему
бы не попахать? Да в начале, когда ты
закладываешь фундамент, приходится
пахать самому. Это это нормально.
И много, конечно, вопросов насчёт
сотрудников задали мои подписчики, моё
окружение. У нас сообщество женщин.
Давай пообсуждаем. И каждый
раз они у меня спрашивают: "Слушай",
говорит, что более важно, когда,
говорит, мы на личные ценности смотрим,
говорит, человека. Угу. Или всё-таки,
говорит, выгода. Ну, типа выгодно возьму
его на работу. Да. Вот как, ну, типа
недорого просит. Недорого просит и
выгодно просто, ну, возьму. Ага.
Ну, когда выбираешь людей в команду, на
что больше нужно делать акцент?
Ну ты сказал ключевое слово, когда
выбираешь людей в команду, а это
подразумевает долгосрочные отношения.
Долгосрочные. Если долгосрочные
отношения, то ценности, прежде всего
ценности. Это первое. Вот я сам лично,
когда люди отбираю, сначала смотрю на
ценности. Второе я на смотрю на его
потенциал, потому что если у него
потенциал маленький, он далеко не
пойдёт. Третье, я смотрю на уровень его
вовлечённости. То есть вообще у я люблю
людей увлекающихся. А для этого
посмотрите в резюме, чем он занимается,
какое хобби, если он ходит там
парашютный спорт, лыжный, ещё языки
изучает, ещё видно, что человек
увлекающийся. А самое плохо взять на
работу, э, без различных ценников. Это
самое плохо. Поэтому я смотрю, человек
увлекающийся или нет. А после этого я
смотрю, потому что увлекающийся он, если
ты вовлечёшь её в работу в компании, он
будет тот, который будет пахать по 10
часов. И четвёртое, я
смотрю, а что включает его увлечённость,
потому что у разных людей разный
стартер. Двигатель, знаешь, когда
заводишь стартер? Кто-то заводится от
денег, кто-то заводится от ценностей,
кто-то заводится от смысла, от большой
идеи, а, изменить мир к лучшему, кто-то
патриотизм, кто-то, ну, это своё, да,
карьеру сделать или славу приобрести и
так далее. Поэтому после того, как ты
вот эти все качества посмотрел, надо
узнать, на каком топливе этот человек
ездит. Это девяносто пятый бензин,
девяносто первый или это на солярке?
А если человек, у него глаза загораются
от бонусов и от денег, блин, долго с ним
ты не проедешь. Угу. Он от тебя уйдёт,
если ты ему не будешь давать постоянно
возрастающие доходы. А если ты будешь
идти на поводу, давать ему бонусы, всё
возрастающее, в какой-то момент у его
доходы будут больше твоих, тебе не
интересны. Поэтому, э, всегда надо
выбирать человека, который загорается от
ценностей, от смысла. И вот мы вернулись
к первому вопросу. Ценности или деньги?
Конечно же, ценности. Начинать надо с
них.
Это это основа. Но здесь ещё нюанс. Есть
нюанс, как в любом правиле, всегда есть
определённые нюансы. А нюанс заключается
вот в чём. Зависит, если ты берёшь,
например, временных сезонных рабочих, то
там чисто за деньги. Ты пришёл,
поработал, вот тебе деньги. До
свидания. Никаких, а длящихся отношений.
никаких длящихся отношений. А если ты
берёшь на работу, на долгосрочную
работу, в команду и тем более на
топменеджмент, то ценности, короче, чем
выше, тем больше значение имеют
ценности. Чем ниже, тем меньше значения
имеют ценности. Поэтому, а если у тебя
ты берёшь на работу человека, который
будет работать уборчестве в офисе, ну
там сильно заморачиваться по поводу
ценностей не надо. Там главное, чтобы
человек не воровал там и и нормальный
был, то есть понимал свою работу и
неконфликтно и всё. Но чем выше позиция,
тем больше внимания уделять надо
ценности. Да. Ну и м в частности у нас
что и происходит в бизнесе, я 15 лет,
ну, основала салон красоты, работала с
парикмахерами, с визажистами.
Там смотришь, вроде бы классный человек,
вроде бы всё супер,
но они начинают всё-таки часто
менять рабочее место. Угу. То же самое,
что и происходит в шей цехах, допустим.
Ну, рабочее место они, наверное, из-за
денег меняют и где-то начинают лучше
платить. Ну, вот это всегда для меня
остаётся вопросом.
Я вот просто бывает иногда не могу
понять из-за
чего. Деньги везде проценты одинаковые.
Что цехах может быть там Угу. на
полцента кто-то больше. У кого-то может
быть ближе к дому.
Ну, в частности. А, а бывает такое, что
а кому-то удобнее, потому что
парикмахерская ближе к клиентам
находится. Потому что парикмакерская -
это такая вещь, обычно ходит не в
парикмахерскую, а к мастеру. Угу. Ну и,
соответственно, мастер подстраивается
иногда бывает под клиентов. Потом ты
начинаешь работать над личным той же
брендом мастера, показывать его на
миллионой аудитории, а потом начинает,
ну, как бы, да, собирать с клиентов и
начинать свой салон открывать. Потом
обратно приходит, касари, можно обратно
мне в команду. Оказывается, я совсем не
предприниматель. С этим я столкнулась в
прошлом году, когда открыла тоже
ресторан.
Я думала: "Ой, надо там
меню, интерьеры шикарные, красивые, всё
необычное, там подача, всё необычное
должно быть". А нет, было были проблемы
с шеф-поварами. Угу. Где я тоже не могла
понять и деньги предлагала, и мотивацию
давала, отдых на Мальдивах боли на Бали.
Ну, с с ними оказывается совсем
по-другому нужно разговаривать. Да, да,
да.
А вроде бы смотришь творческие люди.
Нет, они не совсем творческие люди. Угу.
А и здесь вопрос остаётся больше,
наверное, мотивации. Угу. Да. Вот как
замотивировать, что
ты всё-таки станешь партнёром с ним?
Угу. Чтобы, ну, заинтересовать нужно
менеджера тоже. Угу. Правильно ли, что
ты всегда готова отделиться?
Не всегда. Правильно. Угу. Не всегда
правильно. А нужно чётко понимать
человека, потому что разные люди
мотивируются от разных вещей. Кто-то
мотивируется от большей ответственности,
от вызовов. Кто-то мотивируется от
вызовов. Для него даже деньги. Понятно,
деньги это пускай будут, но мне задачи
покрупнее давай. Мне нравится расти как
личность, потому что когда я решаю
крупные задачи, я чувствую свою
нужность, я чувствую свою крутизну, я
чувствую и расту как личность. Для
кого-то вызовы нужны, для кого-то
безопасность нужна. Короче, я буду всё
вот работать, сделать, чтобы ни
налоговики, ни бухгалтерия, никто ко мне
не приходили. Я буду вот шефу
отчитываться, работать. Я свою работу
буду чётко выполнять, но меня оградить
от всех проблем. Я не хочу проблем.
Кто-то за деньги говорит, за деньги я
готов целыми днями пахать,
путешествовать, ездить и так далее. А
кто-то мотивируется от признания
обязательно, чтобы его всё время
хвалили, продвигали, чтобы его везде
рекламировали. Там вот у меня вот такой
шеф-повар, у меня это, он был у
такого-то человека, он был кормил
таких-то людей. Кто-то мотивируется от
этого. То есть мы очень часто совершаем
ошибку, считая, что мотивация - это
равно деньги. На самом деле нет.
Мотивация - это всё, что двигает
человеком. А человеком двигают не только
деньги. Это и возможность
самореализации, и возможность признания,
и возможность делать большие дела,
возможность
самореализации, деньги тоже в том числе
и так далее. И ещё очень важный момент.
Даже после того, как ты, вот, например,
был один такой случай у моего ученика,
когда они вознаградили, ну,
топ-менеджеров
и мужику, топ-менеджеру подарили резиную
лодку, удочки и так далее, но он
говорит, любит рыбалку. Ну, я говорю,
вот ошибку вы сделали. А он говорит: "А
почему ошибку? Он же любит рыбалку. Мы
ему подарили то, что он любит". Я
говорю: "Нет, вы вот представь, он
пришёл домой с резиновой лодкой и
удочкой, и жена ему говорит: "Блин, мало
ты-то на работе пропадаешь, теперь ты на
своей рыбалке будешь ещё сутками
пропадать". Они говорят: "А что надо
было сделать?" Я говорю: "Вот вы бы
лучше ему подарили там отпуск на
Мальдивах с семьёй". Он бы пришёл на
стол, такой билет: "Та-дан! Смотри,
жена, что мне на работе дали". Жена
сказала бы: "Какая у тебя прекрасная
работа, дети, смотрите, какой у нас
крутой папа". что ему подарили вот
такой-то бонус и так далее, и так далее.
Вы слетали бы на Мальдивы, мужик
гордился бы, и в следующий раз, когда ты
его отправляешь на в командировку, что
бы произошло? Жена первая вынесла бы его
чемодан и сказал: "Бар,
бархажирне, бар". И выгнала бы его из
дому. Поэтому мотивировать надо не
самого человека, а того человека, чьим
мнением он
дорожит. Ну вот, видите, нюансы даже
какие. Да. Ну, многие не показывают
кухню, не открывают
занавески, боятся, наверное. Ну, это
вопрос, как поговорить, на самом деле. А
на самом деле люди очень часто любят,
наоборот, говорить о том, что их
драйвит. Угу. Вопрос, как беседу
поставить? Если правильную беседу
доверительную поставить, люди часами
могут говорить о том, что их драйвит.
Урглалан Колеевич, а я выложила пост о
том, что мы будем ещё выбирать среди
моих подписчиков вот интересные вопросы.
Я выбрала только один из, а, 700. Ух,
нифига себе. Вопрос нам задал, а, тоже
общественный деятель, а, лидер
Абдуррахман. Уважаемый Маргулан
Анколеевич. Мм, также мы тоже хотим
задать вам вопрос. Допустим, у вас есть
свой банк, работающий исключительно по
исламским принципам. Отметьте три
аспекта, на которые вы бы сделали уклон
в его развитии и
продвижении. А, ну первое - это,
конечно, вот если взять наши страны
Казахстан,Кыргызстан, я не знаю
досконально Кыргызстан, но в Казахстане
в первую очередь я бы сделал глубокий
анализ регуляторных требований, потому
что а все проблемы начинаются на уровне
регулирования. Непонятно, непонятные
требования агентства финансового
надзора, есть пробелы в
законодательстве. есть пробелы в
инструкциях. Ну то есть то есть много
противоречащих вещей. И в результате
которого ты делаешь одно, а там
находятся противоречащие статьи, а потом
завтра тебе эту статью тебе припишут
статью уголовного кодекса. Поэтому, а,
сначала нужно прояснить полностью
регуляторный статус исламского банка.
Потому что на словах наши политики
говорят, что они только за, за, за. Но
это же не только слова. Важно же это в
закон. А под законом есть подзаконные
акты, потом есть инструкции, потом есть
приказы и так далее. Да.
Аа это первый момент, на что бы я
обратил внимание. Второй момент, я на
что обратил внимание - это, а, для себя
бы чётко
определил что такое исламский банкинг и
как он будет работать в наших странах. И
в каком плане определил бы, я бы
стандартизировал продукты.
стандартизировать продукты, потому что
проблема любого исламского банкинга в
том, что это очень хорошая вещь. Очень
хорошая вещь. Там нету рыбы, но проблема
в масштабировании. Очень сложно
масштабировать
исламский банкинг. И сложно
масштабировать не в плане того, что
трудно найти людей, кому дать деньги.
Проблема в том, с фондированием.
Проблема трудно найти людей, которые
готовы дать банку деньги.
А если у тебя нету депозиторов, вот в
обычном банке ты берёшь на депозит и
людям платишь проценты, а потом депозит
отдаёшь в кредит. А здесь тебе депозит
ты не можешь принимать, не имеешь права
принимать депозиты. Соответственно, ты
должен у людей брать как акционерный
капитал или ещё каким-то способом. Но
это даже есть депозит там, условно
говоря, с дисконтом, когда ты не
проценты платишь, а там как сукук,
например. Угу. А ты продаёшь там 100 100
долларовую, например, свою облигацию за
80 долларов и говоришь: "Через год я
выкуплю у тебя по 100". А, но всё равно
сложность в том, чтобы привлечь деньги.
Это а вторая такая большая большущая
проблема. Ну и третье, конечно, это
после того, как-то ты прокредитовал
кого-то в исламском банкинге, там залоги
не берёшь, плюс проценты не начисляешь,
соответственно, ты на самом деле
становишься как акционером. Ты
финансируешь в долю, ты даёшь деньги, а
получаешь за это долю в компании.
Ну а здесь, конечно, риски гораздо
больше, потому что в наших странах и
недобросовестность выше, мошенниство
выше, а залоги неликвидные там, ну и так
далее, и так далее. То есть было много
попыток открывать Исламский банк. И в
наших странах пока это не пошло, потому
что, а, и само население не так жёстко и
сильно придерживается принципов шарья.
М. Угу. Поэтому тяжёлый путь, да?
Тяжёлый путь.
Как говорится, у наставника тоже есть
наставник. Да, мне очень интересно м вот
такого
человека, э, для многих вы являетесь,
ну, открыто скажу, что вы для меня тоже
являетесь кумиром. Ну, для многих вы
являетесь тоже, ну, кумиром. Как в
плане у кого у кого нужно учиться, да,
кумиром в плане того, как, ну,
подражание впереди идущий, можно
сказать, впереди идущий. Есть ли у вас
вот кумир или человек, который идёт?
Ну, алика, смотри, а точно кумиров нет.
Кумиров нет. А точно, я считаю, на кого
можно ориентироваться? Наверное, на
нашего пророка саллаллаху алейхи ва
саллям. Плюс на всех сподвижников.
Плюс философы, которых я много
читаю. Ну, наверное, больше вот так. Но
а я меня вот часто спрашивают: "А где я
беру знания, кого читаю и так далее". Ну
я убедился в своей жизни, что основную
часть самых ценных знаний я получил
благодаря размышлениям.
А вот как в исламе есть такое понятие,
по-моему, если я не ошибаюсь, тафакур
называется, где говорится одна один час
размышлений равен целой ночи молитв.
Поэтому вот я очень сильно ценю
размышление. И в этом плане я не создаю
себе кумиров, не беру одного человека
какого-то как источник. Я всё время
сравниваю, э, всё время взвешиваю, читаю
разные источники и так далее, и так
далее. Поэтому, мм, ну,
периодически у меня в жизни, конечно,
получалось очень много встречалось
людей, которым я очень благодарен. И мои
одноклассники, и сокурсники, и учителя,
и мои родственники, друзья, даже враги,
которые создавали мне такую ситуацию, в
результате которых я учился и становился
лучше. В целом я благодарен всем людям,
благодарен Всевышнему.
И на этой весёлой
нотелика разрешили завершить. У нас
сегодняшний был подкаст. К сожалению, у
нас есть тайминг, хронометраж. Я смотрю,
у нас тайминг уже вышел, но вопросы были
очень интересные, особенно то, как ты их
задала, конечно, Анжелика, так в такой
мягкой, деликатной форме. А обычно
бизнес-вопросы, они всегда такие сухие,
рубленные и так далее, но ты очень
красиво это задала. Я уверен вашим
твоим, моим подписчикам это тоже
понравится. Спасибо всем людям, которые
были вовлечены, которые задали эти
вопросы, передали эти вопросы через
Анжелику. Анжелика это, подчеркну, это
человек, с которым я уже год,
оказывается, сегодня знаком. Очень
сильно уважаю. э, очень приятный,
добрый, открытый человек. Спасибо за то,
что ты пришла в эту студию, а,
инициировала эту беседу. Очень приятно
было с тобой беседовать. 45 минут,
конечно, не время, но хоть что-то. В
длинный формат я не решаюсь уйти, потому
что сейчас время такое, люди хотят
быстрее. Но я надеюсь, мы за это
короткое время смогли с тобой принести
пользу и донести людям какие-то мысли.
Спасибо. Спасибо большое. Ждём вас в
Бишкеке, ждём в Кыргызстане. С
удовольствием. А все мои подписчики ждут
и не только мои. Удивительно, знаешь,
что м среди моих подписчиков я смотрю э
статистику. А на первом месте Казахстан,
понятно, на втором месте Россия, на
третьем месте Кыргызстан. И он опережает
Украину.
Потом идёт Украина, потом Узбекистан. В
Кыргызстане так много подписчиков. Я
удивляюсь вообще. Кргыз вообще такой
активный народ-то вообще удивительно.
Поэтому передаю большой привет всем
кргызам. С удовольствием отвечу на их
вопросы и будет возможность, приеду
обязательно. Слёк тоже проводите.
Да, будем спасибо. Ждём всю команду
Кайзен и всю команду Маргулана
Галеевича. Всем огромное спасибо.
Спасибо. Пока.